Німці називають спаржу "овочем королів" або "білим золотом".
З квітня по червень у Німеччині справжній ажіотаж навколо цих білих паростків.
Аби розібратися у феномені популярності спаржі
і показати весь процес від лану до столу, я приїхав
до фермерського господарства родини Ґрайф, що у Трірі.
Це будинок родини фермерів Ґрайф. 1833 рік, рік побудови сімейного гнізда,
вважається часом заснування тут родинної ферми.
Колись у ці величезні ворота заїжджали коні з повозкою.
Вона, до речі, все ще в гаражі і навіть використовується для продажу овочів на ярмарку.
Навколо - чистота й порядок: одразу і не збагнеш, що
прямо через дорогу трактори вивантажують урожай,
а працівники готують його до продажу. Вся родина вийшла познайомитися.
Ось вони - три покоління  Ґрайфів.
Глава родини Ганс-Йозеф Ґрайф є власником і керівником господарства.
На мапі він показує мені всі свої землі. Близько 40% з них - його приватні, решту орендує у міста Трір.
З 1975 року родина Ґрайф на 30 гектарах землі на березі річки Мозель
вирощує фрукти та овочі - від спаржі до вишень.
З кількома постійними робітниками і десятками тимчасових.
До 75 року родина Ґрайф розводила і тварин, однак згодом від цього відмовились:
вирішили, що овочі і фрукти - рентабельніше.
Земля вздовж Мозеля легка, піщана і за сонячної погоди пагони спаржі
ростуть зі швидкістю 8 сантиметрів за добу. Уся спаржа - під чорною плівкою.
– Ми використовуємо чорну плівку для накриття грядки.
По-перше, це утримує вологу всередині,
по-друге, земляні насипи значно швидше нагріваються на сонці, тож і спаржа росте швидше.
Один жест керівника, і робітники зрозуміли сигнал:
треба знімати плівку з насипів. Сьогодні на полі з паном Ґрайфом
двоє працівників: з Польщі та Румунії. На збір урожаю спаржі
загалом додатково приїздять 14 сезонних робітників.
Переважно з Польщі, тоді як українці працюють на польських полях.
Зазвичай для збору спаржі на полях в Німеччині
задіюють близько 300 тисяч сезонних робітників зі Східної Європи.
У мене всі офіційно зареєстровані і мають соціальне страхування.
Отримують мінімальну заробітну платню  - на руки близько 7-7,50 євро за годину.
Про робітників піклується моя дружина, готельна мама.
Все для ночівлі - повністю безкоштовно.
Німці - європейські рекордсмени з поїдання спаржі, до двох кілограмів на рік на людину.
От тільки збирати її вони не дуже люблять.
Ганс-Йозеф з роками вже звик, що до нього їздять робітники зі східних країн-членів Євросоюзу.
Каже, що не проти бачити на своїх полях і українців.
Послуговуючись українською та німецькою, я швидко знайшов спільну мову з поляком Маріушем.
А скажіть, чи важка це робота для вас, важко працювати?
Ні, ні не тяжко, нормально. Робота як робота.
Чи швидко ви навчилися це робити?
Одна година і все окей. Без проблем. Ось так.
А скільки років ви це робите?
6 років.
Маріуш так віртуозно знаходить наосліп пагон під землею, що мені самому закортіло спробувати.
– Ну що ж, майстер-клас від пана Ґрайфа. Зараз спробую зробити це самотужки.
– Спочатку це відкидаю.
Трохи, трохи. Отак всередину. Там внизу пробуй, де пагон.
– Коріння ще треба відчувати.
– Зараз коли його.
І тепер трохи вгору потягни.
Вгору, вгору - є!
– Моя перша шпаргелина у житті!
Схоже, що я впіймав правильний рух.
А от Маріуш цього разу схибив, тож сором'язливо закопав відірвану верхівку.
Для мене було справжнім відкриттям те, що колір спаржі - білий, фіолетовий чи зелений -
від сорту не залежить. Коли біла спаржа потрапляє на сонце,
то набуває фіолетового відтінку. Це барвник антоціан.
Потім починає утворюватися хлорофіл, і з фіолетового стає зеленою.
А через популірність у ФРН  передусім білої спаржі  її бережуть від світла.
Одна з причин ажіотажу навколо білої спаржі – відносно короткий сезон врожаю.
Він починаєтьс у квітні, а закінчується  традиційно 24 червня.
Є така німецька прикмета: «Sind die Kirschen rot, ist der Spargel tot».
Коли вишня почервоніла, то вже спаржа омертвіла.
Після 24 червня, Різдва Іоанна Хрестителя, спаржу вже не накривають.
Після літнього сонцестояння сезон офіційно закритий.
Рослині дають вирости і сформувати насіння.
Сонце потрібне для того, аби рослина набралася сил для зимування.
Тут же, на сусідньому полі, фермер вирощує з насіння саджанці. Це тривалий процес.
Три роки минає, і аж на четвертий рік можна зрізати пагони.
Потім спаржа дає врожай нових пагонів 8 років поспіль.
За годину роботи ми назбирали три кошики.
Ганс-Йозеф Ґрайф у свої 70 бадьорий і веселий, без упину сипле жартами до робітників.
Так, залежить від людини, хтось збирає 5 кілограмів за годину, хтось 10, а дехто і 20.
А бувають і кіло за годину.
Так, є і кілограм за годину.
Далі повертаємось у двір господарства Ґрайфів, де йде підготовка спаржі до продажу.
Процес доволі простий: пагони рівно в один шар, верхівкою догори викладають на конвеєрну стрічку.
Конвеєр подає спаржу  до циркулярної пилки, яка зрізає нерівний нижній край.
До цієї зеленої камери подається вода під тиском.
З камери миття на стрічці виїжджають вже вимиті і охолоджені пагони. Тепер їх треба відсортувати.
Ось це перший сорт,
і далі йде другий сорт.
Ці пагони вже не такі рівні і верхівка деяких з них
прим'ята плівкою, але якість така ж.
Це третій сорт: пагони дещо тонші.
А це верхівки, з коротшими пагонами - раніше це вважалося делікатесом.
А оце роздаровуємо.
Ціни у Ґрайфа такі: перший сорт: 10 євро за кілограм, другий  - 8, третій - 7 євро.
Взагалі у ФРН у сезон ціна на спаржу вищої якості може сягати 15 євро за кілограм.
Тепер її пакують у герметичні ящики, що не пропускають тепло.
А обрізки - на компост. До речі, зверніть увагу, як мальовниче він виглядає.
Друзі, а зараз лайфхак: як розпізнати, що спаржа свіжа?
Берете два пагони і починаєте їх терти одне об одного. Чуєте звук?
Наче пищить якийсь птах - значить, спаржу нещодавно зрізали.
Ну а тепер пагони треба негайно продати, доки свіжі.
Близкість до клієнта - це важливо для фермера з ім'ям.
Родина Ґрайф  торгує на щотижневому сільськогосподарському ярмарку Тріра з 1915 року.
На  вулицах міста, біля траси і в супермаркетах у них кілька торгівельних стендів, які працюють щодня.
Німці традиційно цінують продукти місцевого виробництва.
Постійні клієнти люблять заїжджати у центральну крамницю Ґрайфів, що прямо у них на подвір'ї.
Як ось ця родина з Люксембургу. Там зарплати вищі і ціни також,
тож їздять за фермерськими продуктами у ФРН.
Полуниця виглядає чудово! Саме тому я куплю багато.
А ось ці яблука смакують дуже добре! Такі свіжі! Тут часник і молода цибуля теж високої якості.
Придбали фактично все, що в асортименті.
Фінальний чек - 155 євро!
Такі завзяті покупці надихають. Тож, звичайно, і я не вийшов з крамниці з порожніми руками.
Друзі, я привіз спаржі пана Ґрайфа додому. Саме час її приготувати.
Я готуватиму спаржу за традиційним німецьким рецептом:
варена спаржа, варена картопля і соус Голандезе.
Пагони  треба ретельно почистити.
Волокна шкірки досить грубі і якщо їх недочистити, це може зіпсувати всю страву.
Знімати треба акуратно тільки о сь цей верхній шар.
Пагони мають бути однакової довжини, щоб зваритися одночасно.
Зазвичай нижню частину пагону зрізають.
Я у пана Ґрайфа купив елітну верхню частину, але все одно зріжу трішечки.
Поки доїхав із Тріра до Бонна, кінці пагонів встигли підсохнути та погрубішати,
тож позбавляюсь їх. Воду підсолюю.
Гурмани ще додають цукор та лимон. Кладу спаржу у киплячу воду.
Знову ж таки, гурман би зв’язав її у пучок і поставив у спеціальну високу каструлю,
щоб верхівки пагонів були над водою, бо вони готуються швидше.
Зменшую нагрів і варю 15 хвилин. Саме є час на приготування так званого голландського соусу.
Для вершково-яєчного соусу Голандезе беремо 125 грамів вершкового масла
і ставимо його розтоплюватися на плиту.
Для мене соус - найскладніша частина цього рецепту. Відділяю один яєчний жовток, вичавлюю пів лимона,
додаю 20 грамів води, збиваю міксером і одночасно додаю розтоплене масло.
Наприкінці - трохи солі. Соус готовий!
Тим часом вже зварилася спаржа і картопля. Викладаю все на тарілку.
Ну що ж, а тепер фінальний крок. Заливаємо відварену картоплю і спаржу соусом Голандезе.
Традиційна спаржа по-німецьки готова!
Тепер спробую, наскільки вдалим був мій дебют.
А це справді смачно!
Головне - пам’ятайте:  готова страва подається лише в гарячому вигляді!
Пишіть, що ще вам цікаво знати про Німеччину,
і я обов’язково про це розповім у наступній серії. Побачимося!